Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Ten, Part Two.
Danish science in more recent times.
The Danish-Greenlandic polar explorer Knud Rasmussen, who lived from 1879 to 1933, has been of great importance for the exploration of Greenland and other Arctic areas.
On his seven expeditions in all, the so-called Thule Expeditions, 1912 to 33, he mapped the geography of the areas, collected thousands of objects, for example hunting tools, jewellery and furs, and an extensive knowledge about the Inuit, a number of Arctic peoples.
Of particular importance is regarded his fifth and biggest expedition, 1921 to 24, where he travelled by dog sled 18,000 kilometres from Greenland through northern Canada, Alaska and on over the frozen Bering Strait to eastern Siberia.
On his long journey he explored several Inuit settlements and thereby among other things demonstrated that across very great distances there is a common culture, mythology and traditions among different Inuit tribes.
In the 20th century the Danish physicist Niels Bohr, who lived from 1885 to 1962, achieved international fame.
As a young man he set up a model of the structure of atoms.
For it he received in 1922 the Nobel Prize in Physics.
His most important scientific discovery was however within the so-called quantum mechanics, where Niels Bohr worked together with other leading international researchers.
Niels Bohr took an active part in the political debate about atomic energy and atomic weapons, which his research had made it possible to develop.
The seismologist and geophysicist Inge Lehmann, who lived from 1888 to 1993, proved in an article in 1936, through observations of earthquakes in New Zealand, that the Earth has an inner core.
She was successful as a researcher in the USA, and her studies were used by the American military to calculate the explosive force of test explosions of Soviet atomic bombs during the Cold War.
In 1997 the Danish doctor and scientist Jens Christian Skou, who lived from 1918 to 2018, received the Nobel Prize in Chemistry for his discovery of the so-called sodium-potassium pump, which pumps the chemical substances sodium and potassium out of and into the cells of the human body respectively.
Errors in the sodium-potassium pump lead to heart and nerve diseases.
Jens Christian Skou was professor at Aarhus University, and 40 years passed from when he wrote his first article about his discovery to when he received the Nobel Prize.
Within physics, Lene Vestergaard Hau, born 1959, has made herself noticed internationally.
Lene Vestergaard Hau became really known to the public when in 1999 she reduced the speed of light.
In 2001 she managed to stop a light pulse completely.
Lene Vestergaard Hau is professor at Harvard University in the USA.
Morten Meldal, born 1954, who is professor at the University of Copenhagen, received together with two American researchers the Nobel Prize in Chemistry in 2022 for having laid the foundation for the so-called click chemistry.
With click chemistry you create new molecules with fewer building blocks and thereby fewer chemical reactions than the natural ones.
Click chemistry is also called "molecular LEGO", which can connect molecules without the molecules affecting each other.
In that way you can, for example, more quickly test and produce new medicine.
Here is your recap for Episode Ten.
Tycho Brahe, 1546 to 1601, discovered the new star Nova Stella, and Kepler used his observations.
Niels Steensen, 1638 to 86, showed how we cry and that the heart is a muscle.
Ole Rømer found in 1676 that light has a speed, and prepared the Gregorian calendar, introduced in Denmark in 1700.
Vitus Bering, an explorer, opdagelsesrejsende, sailed through the strait between Siberia and Alaska in 1728, and is buried on Bering Island.
H.C.
Ørsted discovered electromagnetism, elektromagnetisme, in 1820, and coined the Danish words ilt and brint.
Søren Kierkegaard, a philosopher, filosof, who lived in the 1800s, 1813 to 55, wrote Enten – Eller in 1843 and is regarded as the founder of existentialism.
Mathilde Fibiger published Clara Raphael in 1851, and became Denmark's first female civil servant.
Knud Rasmussen, a polar explorer, polarforsker, made seven Thule Expeditions, 1912 to 33, the fifth covering 18,000 kilometres by dog sled.
Niels Bohr received the Nobel Prize in Physics in 1922.
Inge Lehmann proved in 1936 that the Earth has an inner core.
Jens Christian Skou received the Nobel Prize in Chemistry in 1997 for the sodium-potassium pump.
Lene Vestergaard Hau slowed light in 1999, and stopped a light pulse in 2001.
Morten Meldal received the Nobel Prize in Chemistry in 2022 for click chemistry.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Who received the Nobel Prize in Physics in 1922?
Option A: Niels Bohr.
Option B: Jens Christian Skou.
Option C: Johannes V.
Jensen.
[DA] Hvem modtog i 1922 Nobelprisen i fysik?  A: Niels Bohr  |  B: Jens Christian Skou  |  C: Johannes V. Jensen
The answer is A: Niels Bohr.
It appeared in the November 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Niels Bohr
Question 2.
What did the scientist Niels Bohr receive the Nobel Prize for in 1922?
Option A: A method for measuring the speed of light.
Option B: A model of the structure of atoms.
Option C: A theory of the Earth's magnetic field.
[DA] Hvad fik videnskabsmanden Niels Bohr Nobelprisen for i 1922?  A: En metode til måling af lysets hastighed  |  B: En model over atomers opbygning  |  C: En teori om jordens magnetfelt
The answer is B: A model of the structure of atoms.
It appeared in the November 2022 and June 2026 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: En model over atomers opbygning
Question 3.
What was Knud Rasmussen, 1879 to 1933, especially known for?
Option A: He was a composer.
Option B: He was a painter.
Option C: He was a polar explorer.
[DA] Hvad var Knud Rasmussen (1879-1933) særligt kendt for?  A: Han var komponist  |  B: Han var kunstmaler  |  C: Han var polarforsker
The answer is C: He was a polar explorer.
It appeared in the November 2021 and May 2024 exams.
[DA] ✔ C: Han var polarforsker
Question 4.
Which Nobel Prize was Morten Meldal awarded in December 2022?
Option A: The Nobel Prize in Economics.
Option B: The Nobel Prize in Literature.
Option C: The Nobel Prize in Chemistry.
[DA] Hvilken nobelpris blev Morten Meldal tildelt i december 2022?  A: Nobelprisen i økonomi  |  B: Nobelprisen i litteratur  |  C: Nobelprisen i kemi
The answer is C: The Nobel Prize in Chemistry.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: Nobelprisen i kemi
That's the end of this part.
Well done.